hello everyone and welcome back to the
games but stage here at e3 2015 it's
time for my takeover Danny and crisp had
their day it's now time to with me is
Rex and alex from Media Molecule hit a
show off some tearaway unfolded so guys
we obviously played and love tearaway on
the Vita a couple years ago why are we
bringing it to the ps4 well we we felt
that the the story wasn't really
concluded we wanted to kind of branch
out go bigger see if we see if we could
put it up on the big screen when we'd
seen it projected upper like e3's in the
past on a massive projector we thought
that the the art style really held up
and if there was maybe an opportunity to
bring it to the ps4 but obviously we
designed the game so so it was so
integral with the meter hardware that we
weren't sure whether it would be
achievable and and ultimately we had to
kind of tear everything up and start
again and that's where how we've ended
up with a tearaway unfolded let's talk a
little bit about how you've actually
moved from the pizza to the ps4 so
obviously the chill shock for it does
have a touchpad on the front but another
one of the back which is kind of
important because you know the great
moments in the game where your fingers
could pop through excel so how we kind
of maybe change those around a little
bit sure well i mean the the most
important thing for us was to just
identify what things just won't go work
at all and just get rid of them you know
that the obviously that the pushing into
the world is a very very visa specific
thing and it just didn't feel that we
would do it justice by trying to port
that over we tried experiments of like
turning the pad upside down and pushing
on the touchpad it's just you know some
mad idea so we just moved away from that
got the whole team together as a game
jam and like just really explored what
was what was knew about the jewel shop
for and there's just a whole bunch of
features on there that we didn't feel it
being really exploited yet yeah so let's
talk a little bit about what what you've
actually implemented because I mean
especially in games nowadays the
touchpad is kind of wasted
I feel like it's not really living up to
its potential it's usually used as a
pause menu yeah so what are you done um
so well as alex is going to show us now
as we swipe into the world on the
touchpad it sends a gust of wind into
the into the paper world you can see how
it's all like folding and changing as we
as we go through the environment and you
know in a world that's so so fragile
it's there's a you can really feel quite
powerful you know just a simple swipe
and you see how it's all changing and
unfolding we went early in the
development of tearaway we had a pop-up
book engineer come in and like show us
how pop-up books work and is really
really fascinating to sort of get into
the the mechanics of what is possible
with paper yeah so we can see here the
gust of wind what are the new
functionality go to say again sorry so
we see the width the gust of wind here
what else are we gonna be able to see
you'll be able to see we can also use
the the light on the controller to shine
into the world it felt that it's kind of
a mad thing to see this triangle of
light shining out of the back of your
control there all the time maybe it
should actually shine into the TV so as
you move into like a darker space you
actually see how it's how it illuminates
the the messengers journey and reveals a
whole bunch of other stuff Alex at the
moment is taking a bunch of photos we
you know it's a very unusual looking
game so and we found on the Vita that
that the fans really enjoyed taking a
lot of photos and sharing those we've
expanded that out with a bunch of new
filters and you can see here the
animated gif lens that's my favorite one
so you can actually make your own little
gifts upload them online Oh wonderful
that's also it also seems a better
because whenever I was in public and i
would i'd have to take a photo and taro
and a sort of fight yeah try i tried not
like i'm being suspicious on a train or
something exactly um so a big part of it
as well is that they use the pitas front
camera to put you into the game because
obviously you are down the Sun you're
part of the game one of my people who
maybe don't have a place day
camera well we've we've developed a new
app it's actually uses the PlayStation
app so you don't need to down anything
new but if you've got a tablet or a
phone lying around then you can fire up
the app on there you can start creating
on their sending things into the world
start taking photos the photos will go
on to any any paper that's near at well
while she's standing so you can sort of
player 1 can be running around and
player 2 is like adding in textures and
it's kind of a way of really
personalizing everyone's experience
that's wonderful I mean that because
that is a big a big thing of media
epidemic you'll your ethos is kind of
create and share yeah um and how has the
reaction been to tear away obviously
were a little bit littlebigplanet it's
more obvious because you can see
fan-created levels lunch with Tara way
it's mostly people posting really
adorable pictures of Artois to Twitter
yeah no I mean it's it was it was very
important to us to sort of kind of grow
the studio in terms of making a very
story based game and something that was
had you know a good a good single player
experience and then experiment with ways
to to bring in the the creative elements
but as part of the overall package
rather than being something that off to
one side you know like in editor or and
it was an interesting experiment to us
to try and combine creativity with
storytelling and you're so it was your
tear away was your idea wasn't it works
I believe well it's everyone's idea I
mean I'd I just wanted to make something
that was very tangible very physical and
something and that ultimately meant
making out of paper yeah but it was it
was really that was just the sort of the
kick off point for the whole team to
then get together and gain jam on that
and come up with ways to to make a very
tangible papery world because I mean you
guys always had the best foods it shows
because even the creativity of the team
would be displayed not only virtually
but in real life as well yeah I mean we
just can't help ourselves really you
know we we really enjoy playing playing
our games making games and we
just try and try and bring that out into
the world and I need hopefully inspire
players to get involved and make things
themselves so you mentioned that you
felt like there was more story to tell
so is that going to be in its own
separate you know post where we know the
taraweeh actually ends or is it going to
be integrated into me yeah no I mean
it's it's it's still the same overall
kind of journey that you're going on but
there's a lot of twists and turns along
the way we've we've widened the game out
so that you have more side things to
find the more tricky stuff to to battle
with and deal with as alex is just about
to take on some scraps here and yet
we've some of the some of the areas that
we didn't we didn't feel were quite as
like fully formed on the on the vita
version we've we've been able to develop
a little bit more there's a new
conclusion to the end of the second part
of the game so we playing to be a lot of
surprises i think for vita players as
well as you know for new new ones so
let's talk a little bit what we've just
seen there um Alex I noticed you were
sort of at always throwing things at you
and you were chuck it down back um how
is that going to be changing up the way
that we blow so one of the things we
wanted to do is really explore or play
with the idea of the game being inside
of the TV and you holding the controller
and there being like a relationship
between the two and the most tangible
way that we do that is that you can at
work and pick up objects in the game and
then throw them out to you you catch
them in your controller and then you can
shake them around kind of annoy them if
it's a little character and then you can
swipe on the touchpad and it will go
flying back into the game again so you
can use kind of use enemies as
projectiles and you can you can have all
kinds of sort of emergent fun with with
the various systems that we've got it
feels like I mean that's the thing what
Tara wait said so maybe some other games
on the Vita when they came out they felt
like the beetus functionality was kind
of shoehorned in a little bit like it
was kind of force that you'd use it with
Tara way it didn't it felt like a
natural thing because you wanted to
reach in and touch that world and it's
nice to see that that's carried over
place different
yeah I think it helps to have like a
very very strong sort of metaphor at the
group that really binds the whole game
together with like the paper world you
know and as long as we get that right we
can actually start tearing away the
fourth wall all the time and and play
with it a lot more which which i think
you know work worked out well on Vita
and we're taking it further with
unfolded something that's really really
pleased with is that a lot of the powers
that we've added are you can use them up
pretty much at any time so it's it
becomes a more personal you can play in
a more personal way you know it's like
use it use the powers that you like the
most to to deal in a battle whether you
want to like swipe the enemies with wind
and see them tumbling off a mountainside
whether you want to throw them out into
the pad and shoot them into the side of
the mountain or you know there's a whole
bunch of different ways to to play with
the same content Andy what when I played
the game I just sort of I immediately
fell in love with without well I mean
it's impossible not to how do you forge
that bond between player and essentially
a player a player vessel eyes um I think
I mean one of my favorite things is
actually quite a subtle subtle element
of the game is that as it was running
along she often like just look over her
shoulder she's kind of she's aware of
the fact that we're outside of the game
and we are we kind of going on this
journey with her and we've been adding
in a lot of new animations and reactions
so that just bring a little more of her
character out yeah as you can see here
we've just moved into this dark section
is and by squeezing the squeezing the
trigger we'll see how the light from the
DualShock shines into the world I mean
in in some form it's is kind of like a
torch but you know we treat it as much
more than a torch it's a very sort of
godly kind of torch that's shining in
and changing the world it retains the
shape as well which came it's a great
another great way of sort of making that
bun this move yeah um so what I mean is
there gonna be new trophy support I
assume deposition for what yep share
yeah everyone's gonna be sharing oh yeah
this world
I mean yeah exactly yes yes yep yeah we
yeah there will be gifts everywhere
tearaway dot me website will be all that
all the content from the ps4 version
will be going up there as well so
players can can see what the kind of
stories and experiences that other
players are having and you know
hopefully just spam the world with gifts
you know there's there's been enough
cats on the internet now we need some
squirrels the end the time of the cats
is over you heard it here first guys
thank you so much for joining me Alex
Rex make sure you stay tuned to the game
sports stage because we've got so many
amazing games coming out tell me quickly
though when is tearaway unfolded hitting
on PlayStation force it is out in strong
September septum early don't tell us in
the ninth in Europe Oh guys thank you so
much make sure you stay tuned to
gamespot for more coverage from e3 2015